you know I know rain Pryor yeah you know
Richard Pryor's daughter when I started
doing stand-up we had o Muhammad Ali's
daughter maymay Ali who was a regular at
the store
mm-hmm rain would go up too and I always
thought to myself like how difficult
especially for rain prior being the
daughter of Richard Pryor if you think
that's crazy
ok so Mason Pryor do you know Mason no
this is the son yeah this is real son
they look just alike
know what Mason Pryor yeah Mason Brier
so Haddish oh we were all at open mic
and I forgot who was hosting [ __ ]
Benji Benji was hosting and I'm Tiffany
Haddish it went up or whatever she did
she she did this thing where she like
queef in the microphone funniest [ __ ] of
all right so I it would kill it would
destroy whatever and then so um so Benji
was like Benji was like you know what
he's like that's so funny he's like I
want you to sit on the side all right
and he's a anyone who's terrible what a
great show idea Mason Pryor the son who
hits yeah yeah his adventures like Oh
God like this is a setup a legend and
this is eat me right he looked over yeah
he was like oh he was about what the
[ __ ] evoke we've gone before
[ __ ] for yeah she was like you got a
braid
oh you know what you and Hannah are
similar in that way when you bring up
hat and you guys are close right yeah
yeah guys are like could be brothers and
sisters yeah yeah in terms of style
mhm and you know she dude be whatever
you want about her dude when we did that
was that musical show I did for damn
comedy Jim on Comedy Central it went it
went Chris Hardwick yeah he did it with
what's a guitar legend Stevie Ray
Vaughan or no no you did it with Richie
Sambora December either one right yeah
so there imagine they're the left this
is the last show yeah this already so
Chris Hardwick he's on a show on Comedy
Central at the time then Haddish goes up
there and does Aretha Franklin attorney
and it was one of the greatest live
performances of anything I've ever seen
crushed and then I have to go up I don't
know the words no I had to pull my dick
out and it worked in a world Brodie spot
and and I was doing like this weird
character they had like green tights or
whatever was like a dinosaur or whatever
and then I went back to go change to my
regular clothes but I had to take off my
arm I had to take off the tights
whatever and I noticed I didn't have any
underwear under my tights and so I was
like I was like oh man how's that [ __ ]
you know it'll be funny I'll say yeah
walk out there naked yeah
anyway they were like oh my god and they
turned off the lights and they Jamar you
can't do that clothes on wine that's
where the comedy stirs wrong yeah we
used to be able to do that yeah people
like you had the freedom to do it Yeah
right I want to see your thick dick to
it one day let's not make this let's
make this the foundation of a new newer
friendship okay you have a podcast oh I
don't have anything well one day we'll
get you on all right all right yes